ville brésilienne la plus peuplée avec
plus de 12 millions d'habitants
sao paulo est également la ville la plus
touchée du pays avec près de 130 mille
cas confirmés et plus de 1500 décès au
cimetière villa formosa le plus grand
d'amérique latine
le travail des fossoyeurs a plus que
doublé avant le coronavirus james et son
équipe procédèrent environ 30 inhumation
par jour
aujourd'hui ils en sont à 80 l'arrivée
du nouveau coronavirus a complètement
changé notre rythme de travail
au début on enterrait entre trois et
cinq victimes
ducobu 19 par jour maintenant nous
enterrons 32 35 victimes du coronavirus
en une seule journée dans le cimetière
de ville à formosa 8000 nouvelles tombes
ont été creusées dans des zones non
utilisés depuis plus de trente ans jour
après jour le brésil s'enfonce dans le
chaos sanitaires le système hospitalier
public du pays est saturé dans presque
toutes les régions à sao paulo
presque deux mille patients atteints du
coc vie 19 sont hospitalisés en soins
intensifs le plus important hôpital de
la ville ne compte que 50 lits de
réanimation tous occupés depuis le mois
d'avril
si les autorités recensent plus de 600
mille cas certains médecins et
chercheurs estiment qu'ils pourraient y
avoir 3 millions de personnes infectées
c'est un fait ce n'est pas juste une
impression les chiffres sont sous
déclaré nous ne voyons que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg
la plupart des cas ne sont pas déclarés
ils sont invisibles car nous ne pouvons
pas les diagnostics et il n'y a pas
assez de test pour cela les personnes
les plus vulnérables face au virus
habitent dans des favelas
l'absence de l'état se fait criante dans
ces quartiers défavorisés comme appareil
sopo lice deuxième plus grand quartier
pauvre de sao paulo où vivent plus de
cent mille personnes jugées trop
difficiles d'accès ou trop dangereux les
pompiers les secours médicaux refuse
d'entrer dans ses rues l'association des
habitants de pareils sow police a réussi
à récolter plus de 40000 euros
cette cagnotte a servi à embaucher une
équipe médicale à plein temps pour
soigner les malades
cette pandémie ne choisit pas entre
pauvres ou riches
peu importe la classe sociale tout le
monde est dans le même bateau clos mais
de l'argent ou non mais quand une
pandémie comme celle ci frappe les
favelas la situation devient compliquée
si les favelas ne s'organise pas
d'elle-même
on va perdre beaucoup de nos proches et
l'exemple de paraiso police est loin
d'être isolé au brésil plus de 13
millions de personnes habitent dans des
favelas